walk him to this video what is this our
camera in the house Platon numerous
times okay the wiki h6 line but it's not
so bad surprising me making a neat
little hole on age 74 the bishop here we
go okay so he's intending to play Queen
B 3 i'm attacking f7 and to be seven let
some make sure nothing bad happens play
em play 60 d
okay I wasn't sure if I should play 97
first to make sure 95 is not coming but
95 my it's not not so dangerous I hope
yeah he's going for it yeah this type of
structures and is pretty comfortable for
black I think I had almost this exact
position in this tournament in Austria
against unknown international master
from India and we quickly agreed to a
draw I felt this was a good result there
at the time
okay mother yeah I cannot take with the
seat bone because of Queen B 5 but this
this should be okay ok it's just
exchanging him hmm yeah interesting I
could just exchange here I can try to to
keep keep the bishop take it retreated
to e7 and how to town
yeah I don't think I want to I cruelty
form hmm
okay need to evacuate the queen that
doesn't have many squares I think now
I'm I more or less some forcing the
exchange a 2 was saying and now i have d
three years square for my bishop which
blocks the default and allows me to put
something on the aid yeah now the idea
he can try f4 f5 try to use his four
against three majority interesting
position hard to judge I think at least
for me it's hard to judge
maybe you should try to open up the
position with e6 on some something like
that Bishop somewhere a bishop not
Bishop d5 can maybe play c5 they are
debatable what I'm getting at is maybe
it should try to prepare yeah this was
also an idea try to prepare e6 yeah
that's just the texture 70 and on f4 is
controlling d3 okay i can i can do that
niger seventh king of eight hmm he could
try nitrous and king of eight group d 7
maybe but it's beyond that said I win
apiece check Wow we know this is a WoW
ok now I didn't see that one hmm ok
takes pawn takes now I cannot really
save the bishop then
okay yeah it's not clear if this flashy
idea really net something check
ya can repeat moves Knight f6 check
channels check yeah okay I just I just
don't like to draw maybe it this is a
foolish decision but I like to I'd like
to continue the game okay
yeah the funny thing is this night it
doesn't have a square really go here
right f Bishop f5
maybe night b8 how it looks completely
wacky but maybe not be aid they could
have gone to be eight I think
ok so how to how to convert this I need
f6 young I need to play f6 get rid of
the night
can go all the way to deform and wait
with the king check oh I have many many
self mates possible
unnecessary was that it was just idiotic
to go there really okay
time morning it wasn't even bent it
seems now but just leading to a very
tricky position yeah no it's it's it's
it's working to perfection check check
check white resigns yeah wow this was
completely completely unnecessary to get
the King into the stroller maybe it was
was Eve good but I couldn't see night
situ at all getting to getting to this
check square only three dad seems that
he cannot really touch the King here the
computer is our he can win night see
fortnight f5 winning for white 95 why
why is this winning okay no why King
cool I don't get it look I just jacked
his threatening g7 and drooped at 96
okay okay so on I I shouldn't play be
sure before I should play this one
yawa it was completely unnecessary
around here this is this is very good
for me even I was so focused on getting
the night out with f 6 I forgot to to
just secure the pawn yeah yeah I should
play play like this is just secure some
a safe edge for black not giving up the
pawn yeah and no one I went to this
crazy bit crazy oops this crazy path all
the way to h3 okay thanks for watching